so I had a meme they put up on the
Instagram the other day of how every
dude whose girlfriend is paying for
everything stands and it's like a guy
standing with his arm deep around the
girl like oh they're waiting in line for
things baby in public always baby
holding a hand you can't get my husband
to hold my hand
do you know why can you pay the mortgage
my husband funniest [ __ ] so I said hey I
said up baby
you want some [ __ ] he said not at all
[Laughter]
he said not at all Joe we bought a Sleep
Number bed
and he was like cuz his knee was missing
them by the Sleep Number bed I'm gonna
put it on everything I'm like [ __ ] yeah
so I just got a deal with Fox for my TV
show so I walk it out I walk in the damn
mom sleeping I'm like a real negro when
they get some money give me the best
[ __ ] bad you won't cuz I'm gonna [ __ ]
every night Sleep Number bed but I
should have no you were gonna do [ __ ]
cuz he was insistent on getting a metric
that split down the middle you know the
two metric separate let's just split
down the middle and he'll hear time I
want to see hey you want to come to
American get reduce all fall down
clovie and in that we don't gave up we
just [ __ ] the middle and by the time
we get met through the [ __ ] matches
on fell off the bed cuz we in the middle
with a whole lap remote my wit my TV
show home buy me a magic put those back
the [ __ ] gay
[Music]